i think the difference here is guys
harvey weinstein
yeah that guy's a
corrupt criminal right class a dirk bag
so you go to r kelly story is what
13 year old you know and indeed
breaking the law right so both broke the
law you go to what was the name next
name that you said michael jackson all
right so that you know
the stories you hear from there okay
that's a completely different story but
he did make thriller
yeah he did i i get that and by the way
like kevin spacey to me kevin spacey is
yes one of the best actors of our
generation i mean the guy
how you know kaiser so say you know you
can go up and say so many different
things what this guy did there is the
law
and then there is intent and then there
is personal life you know
trevor bower i don't know if you guys
know what trevor bowers first is the
pitcher for the dodgers who's got a
he had a three-year contract for 108
million dollars i think it was like a 90
million dollars was the contract with 10
10 million dollar bonus or 18 million
dollar bonus
young award winner
young award winner which is called the
mickey mouse award winner right this guy
gets suspended for two years did you see
that yeah based two years they suspended
him they're not even and
all charges were dropped against trevor
that's what's crazy about it can you
make it bigger by the way can you make
it bigger so we can read this so all
charges were dropped on trevor bauer
this is this is just talking about how
much money he's gonna lose he's gonna
lose uh 102 million dollars excuse me no
he's going to lose
roughly 47 million dollars in salary so
so
whatever the number is the guy's going
to lose a lot of money okay so he goes
in a relationship with a girl and they
say hey i like
this style of sex and she says
okay so you said you believe johnny depp
is a fan of rough sex so they have rough
sex the sex was so rough that she came
back for another time okay
so then second time around they have
rough sex then she goes out and says
well he did xyz to me then they dropped
the case then they dropped all the
charges that he got and then the mlb
suspends him for two years and you're
gonna take nearly 60 million dollars
away from this guy who's a cy young
winner who is one hell of a pitcher
you're gonna do that that's
is there a law there or is that just mlb
making a decision to do that so in this
case with johnny and amber
johnny filed for divorce and johnny is
the one that's like listen
here's what happened she's dropping my
name out there and defame and
everybody's thinking i'm a bad guy i'm
not a bad guy and then you get all these
other guys that are coming and say look
i've done cocaine i probably did you do
drugs with that person yes did you do a
drug with this person yes why'd you do
drugs with that person i'm not gonna lie
to you i just wanted him to shut up
because he was talking too much right i
don't know who he was talking about
manson or one of those guys right but
he's just
talking straight up right you're going
through this there's a part of this that
you have to be
very very careful there are people out
there relationship wise that if you're
in a bad relationship it's realistic
that you can
you can have your career being hurt if
you date the wrong person you have to be
so careful in hollywood you know who
you're married you have to be so careful
in sports who you're married all of this
stuff you know the movie fifty shades of
grey i don't know i know tyler's one of
his favorite books he's read it multiple
times all three always quote you always
quote things out of the book but uh i
actually read 50 shades of grey okay
when the book came out everybody in the
office was you know secretly like what
color you know how that book is the kind
of book where you cover with paper like
it's like when you were in high school
yeah you have like your homework and you
got playboy right in the middle what are
you doing i'm just doing my homework you
know you got
so but everyone said what are you
reading no nothing nothing listen what
are you reading so finally you're like
okay so what is this all about so
finally i read the book
and there's a part of it in there where
he gets the girl to sign a contract
right i mean is it to that point
where it's like hey
trevor bauer's going to be like hey mary
i like you here's what i'd like to do
my lawyer can you please explain to them
what's about to happen here yeah can you
imagine that setting it's like yes okay
so let me read you your rights and you
know let me read you the contract here's
what's going to happen tonight you're
going to participate in xyz are you open
to this if you get hurt and your body
lip up sign right here is that what it's
going to get to no 100
that's where we're going i think 100 i
think that's a great idea a little
documentary
if you're a big profile celebrity if
you're johnny depp if you're a cy young
award winner and you're making 100
million dollars if you're a famous nba
star if you're a famous hollywood guy
you have your pick of the litter
facts there's no question about it okay
so you could have amber heard you could
have this person that person okay listen
sweetheart you know we got a thing going
on before this goes any further i'm
gonna need you to sign this right if
they're willing to sign it all right you
guys can do what you guys want to do i'm
shocked they didn't have that signed
beforehand i'm shocked these guys don't
have lawyers saying johnny like you have
a hundred million dollar career at risk
and you're gonna put it because you like
to have a good time with this girl
if i'm that person's handler that
manager that agent
you gotta have these conversations sure
signs were had 100 have to be had
your whole career will go down the tubes
because you like kinky sex with amber
hurt right i had a guy by the way that
said the following i can't you know this
is a guy that's
not a well-known guy but a known guy he
said no joke he said here's all i do
he said i have my phone
and i get a video
and i produce the video with them and i
say hi i'm john doe
what's your name such and such
we
are you agreeing to do xyz with me yes
can you please say that are you okay do
you feel safe yes can i open a door
where you can live if you want to yes
you can leave if you want to i don't
want to do you want to leave i don't
want to leave you sure yeah okay let me
just give you tour the entire place it's
just me there's nobody else here he's
kind of going like 30 second video yeah
and he said yeah perfect thank you and
he files that for himself
in case this ever turns around complete
sense i tell you as weird as this sounds
yes i'm in the army i'm 18. okay drill
sergeant
drill sergeants and my sergeant braxton
said hey
whatever you do right before you're
about to have sex ask for the idea
so the guys are like what are you
talking about he says ask for the idea
you got to do it so you're serious yeah
so we go to a party all right it's
getting to that point there's three
rooms that are open hey can i see your
id you want to see my id that's stupid
yeah i know believe me i also think it's
stupid but can i see your id no
i can't get in there you're serious now
you have to realize at this point it's
the most frustrating moment for an 18
year old boy think about being 18 years
old right at that moment but i got to
see your id shows the addition 16. okay
my guy had to run out they're like hey
we got to get out of here we're back to
the base right it's getting to that
point where people have to do such
things to get protected so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]